hello is this thing working can you guys  hear me  hello hello  yes  yes we're going we gotta we got the uh  uh we're  live with the ah yeah we're going uh  yeah sorry about the mic setup it's  total trash you know but but i've been  moving so  are my levels too low how are my levels  my level i'm sorry my dudes i gotta  forgot i need to post the link on  twitter yeah there's a lot of stuff i  should have checked before i went live  that i probably should have inspected  but i impulsively started the stream  without checking any of those things i'm  gonna have to do them now because i  didn't have the foresight nor discipline  to do it earlier  what's up gamers